there's a feel-good story of the day
coming out of norco california norco
california is in riverside county which
is east of los angeles
uh a convenience store owner was just
minding his own business work in the
convenience store and some thugs bust
into the store with a gun with a pretty
gnarly looking gun and they assume they
can just rob the store get out of there
with the money no big deal they didn't
count on the 80 year old owner of the
store
pulling a total clint eastwood a full-on
gran torino dirty hairy and grabbing his
shotgun and blasting off the robber's
arm
so we've got the footage from the store
the counter cope whipped out his hidden
shotgun and
blasted the suspect in the arm as the
man took off another camera captured
this
the suspects after nearly leaving one of
their own behind sped off in a black bmw
x3
he shot my arm off he shot my arm off
which is funny because you can it looks
like he's still got his arm maybe it's
just kind of dangling in the sleeve or
something there
feel good story of the day i'm so
glad this man this 80 year old clint
eastwood did the world a public service
he didn't get off scot-free either by
the way i think he had a heart attack as
a result of this imagine you're 80 years
old guys bust in with a black rifle to
rob your store and you have the courage
and you have the quick quick thinking to
grab your gun and blast him away still
that's a traumatic experience for
anybody even if you're 30 years old
especially if you're 80. i think he's
doing okay though he did a courageous
wonderful thing a real public service
because
when criminals get away with acts of
crime that encourages more people to
become criminals that encourages more
criminals to commit more crime and it
just kind of blossoms from there this
was the premise of the the broken
windows policing policy in giuliani's
new york that worked like a charm the
premise was if you see broken windows
you got to go you got to go take care of
that right away you can't let the
problem fester if you see little acts of
crime if you see vagrants if you see
you've got to stop that and arrest the
criminals and clean it up because if you
don't pretty soon you're gonna have much
more severe acts of crime and it's gonna
be much more widespread and that's
that's what happens so when when
criminals think they can bust into a
store and just rob the cash register and
get away with it you're gonna see a lot
more convenience store robberies when
when gran torino over there shows up and
blasts off the robber's arm that sends a
very healthy important message not just
to the robber whether he gets to keep
his arm or not but all to all of the
other ones as well it's another reminder
too
as the political order falls apart as it
is doing right now
we are seeing crime go through the roof
we are seeing our trust in our civic
institutions collapsing we can't even
speak the same language half the time
not just because the libs are flooding
the country with foreign nationals who
don't speak english but because the libs
themselves don't speak english they
can't even tell you what a man or a
woman is as you see the political order
collapsing it is very important to be
able to protect yourself you just saw it
down in uvalde the democrats are talking
about uvalde
as a way to attack the police
departments rightly so in the case of
uvalde in that that elementary school
shooting and they're saying we can't
rely on the cops to come protect us and
conservatives are out there and they're
saying you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right we can't count
on the cops that's why we have to
protect ourselves i'm so glad you're
making our point for us i'm so glad
you're making a strong argument for the
second amendment
yeah you need to you need to be able to
have a gun you need to be able to
protect yourself
you need to be able to exercise your
constitutional and civil and natural
rights for that matter right now head on
over to ring.com
knowles summer is very very busy people
are going all over the place a lot of
people are going on vacation i just had
my second little baby boy so i was away
from home i was in the hospital for a
few days we're going to be moving all
over the place want to make sure that my
home and my family are protected that's
why you need a ring you all know about
rings video doorbell where you can see
and speak to whoever is at your doorstep
no matter where you are in the world did
you know that ring has an alarm system
maybe you've heard about it ring alarm
it's fabulous you can keep track of your
doors your windows everything in your
physical home well did you know that
ring alarm has gone pro that's right
ring alarm pro is in the words of cnet a
giant leap for home security because it
protects not only your physical home but
your digital home too it combines a
security system with a fast ero wi-fi 6
router for home security and network
security in one device we live so much
of our lives in the virtual world make
sure you protect that as well as your
physical home this busy summer season to
protect your home you got to go pro be a
pro be like me okay get ring alarm pro
learn more at ring.com knowles that is
ring.com
knowles
did you like that clip i certainly did
thank you so much for helping us to
reach 1 million youtube subscribers
that's huge now next goal 1 billion
that's right ring the bell subscribe get
the notifications we will see you
at a billion
[Music]
[Music]
you